[Music]
hello friends and welcome to met
simplified in this video we will discuss
about mitosis in simple terms mitosis is
a small phase in the whole process or
cell cycle in which the nucleus of the
cell divides into two before progressing
any further make sure you have watched
the videos on cell cycle on our channel
as that video is key to understand the
topics in this video link below before
starting with the topic I would like to
announce that we are launching the med
simplified merchandise store on T spring
comm support met simplified and get your
favorite colors and designs on t-shirts
mugs phone cases and much more visit
link in the description to check it out
now as you know the cell cycle is
divided into two main phases the
interface or the M phase interface is a
time during which the cell grows and
prepares for division and during the M
phase the cell actually splits into two
the M phase is further divided into two
phases karyokinesis and cytokinesis the
word kirio means nucleus and the
kindnesses means movement so
karyokinesis is movement or splitting of
the nucleus and cytokinesis means cell
movement or splitting of the cytoplasm
the karyokinesis or the nucleus
splitting is also known as mitosis so I
hope you understand the overview about
what is mitosis now in this video we
will study what are the important events
that happen before the nucleus actually
start splitting then we will talk about
one important structure in the cell that
is very important for mitosis and then
we'll study the steps of mitosis in
detail so let's first look at some of
the important events that take place in
the cell before the actual nucleus
splitting the cell starts splitting here
in this red zone first the nucleus
splits and then the cytoplasm before the
cell undergoes nucleus pitting it has
already undergone through the interphase
which is highlighted in blue color which
is the time the cell takes to prepare
for division the interphase is further
divided into three stages g1 s and g2
phase during the g1 and g2 phase the
cell gains nutrients grows in size and
function and makes more of cell
organelle ease interesting things happen
in the S phase S phase or the synthesis
phase is associated with synthesis of
new DNA from already existing DNA or
whole DNA is copied using special
molecular machines in a complex process
known as DNA replication so this is cell
and here is its nucleus present inside
the nucleus is its DNA which is folded
like a long coiled noodle if we take out
this DNA it would look something like
this now during the S phase the cell
uses the process of DNA replication and
forms an exact copy of this set of DNA
this DNA is later parked in the form of
chromosomes and then equally divided in
the two new nuclei so the cell has
synthesized a new set of DNA to be used
later and has gone through the
preparatory phase of interphase and is
now ready for nuclear division so these
were the events that take place in the
cell before the actual division next we
will talk about one important structure
inside the cell that is essential for
proper splitting of the nucleus the
mitotic spindle the mitotic spindle
consists of centrosomes and microtubules
which are the rope-like structures
projecting from centrosomes the word
centrosome is often confused with the
word centromere this is a centromere
the part that you see in the center of a
chromosome which is different from
centrosome which is the structure here
which helps in dividing the contents of
nucleus into two the functioning of the
mitotic spindle can be compared to a
lifting crane the centrosomes can be
compared to a motor and a microtubules
are just like ropes which pull anything
that is attached to them if we look
closely at the structure of the
centrosome we can see that it is made up
of two centrioles which are cylindrical
structures that are made up of the
protein tubulin during the S phase the
centrosomes also duplicate and the cell
has two centrosomes now which migrate to
the opposite ends of the cell
microtubules are hollow tubes 24 to 25
nanometers in diameter and they are also
composed mainly of the protein tubulin
they are attached to a centrosome on one
side and on the other side the
microtubules attached to the central
mayor of the chromosome which we
discussed earlier now if we look at this
chromosome it is made up of four arms
connected in the center to a centromere
this chromosome with four arms
represents two chromosomes actually the
red part here represents the duplicated
DNA which is yet attached to the parent
DNA and in mitosis we break this
duplicated chromosome from the center to
get two new chromosomes and to break
this chromosome equally the two
microtubules from the opposite ends of
the cell attached to one chromosome at
its center or centromere when these
microtubules pull this chromosome in
opposite directions it breaks in the
center to divide into two new
chromosomes so these were some important
things that you needed to know before we
start discussing the actual process of
mitosis now let's dive into how mitosis
actually takes place the whole process
of mitosis is divided into four simple
stages prophase metaphase anaphase and
telophase and the basic concept of each
of them is condensation alignment
splitting and nuclear membrane formation
I will explain all this in a bit so
first coming to the prophase the world
that we use for it was condensation now
what does that mean our DNA is very long
like 2344 kilometers long really so to
fit all that in one tiny nucleus is a
daunting task and to achieve this our
nucleus packs the DNA not in suitcases
of course but it packs the DNA around
special structures in the nucleus like
histones this can be compared to finding
a villain thread in a ball like manner
which allows a really long thread to fit
in a small place now this packing can be
loose or tight depending upon what the
cell wants to at that time if this
is living fine and doing it stuff the
packing is loose so that the cell can
read what's on the DNA to form proteins
and other stuff but during mitosis we
need a tight packing because it is more
stable and prevents DNA damage when
chromosomes divide in the cell this
tight packing is known as condensation
so the first thing that a cell does as
it starts with the process of mitosis is
to pack its DNA into chromosomes so that
it doesn't get damaged in the coming
steps also the nucleolus disappears from
the cell during this phase only so this
was prophase next we have the metaphase
the metaphase is actually divided into
two phases a prometaphase and an actual
metaphase now here is the cell after the
prophase the chromosomes are present in
the nucleus in prometaphase the membrane
around the nucleus disappears it breaks
up into small vesicles which are later
used to make the nuclear membrane of
newly formed nuclei due to this the
chromosomes are now lying freely in the
cytoplasm of the cell
then comes a roll of mitotic spindle the
microtubules from the spindle attached
to the centromere of the chromosomes and
if you look closely you can see that two
microtubules attached to one centromere
each of these microtubules comes from
the centrosome on the opposite end after
the prometaphase we have an actual
metaphase which we described with the
world alignment the centrosomes now
start to pull the chromosomes toward the
opposite ends of the cell the resulting
tension causes the chromosomes to align
along the metaphase plate or the
equatorial plate so this was arrangement
alignment or metaphase next we have the
anaphase or the actual splitting the
centrosomes that act like motors start
to pull on the ropes that are the
microtubules
now since the microtubules are exerting
forces on the chromosomes the cohesions
which are molecules that keep the
duplicated arms of
chromosomes together are broken down
this results in chromosomes being split
in the center into two equal and new
chromosomes the microtubules continue to
pull the chromosomes and due to this one
set of chromosomes reaches to one pole
of the cell and the other set reaches
the opposite pole who these sets of
chromosomes are exactly the same the
next phase is the telophase which is
nothing special but formation of new
nuclear membrane around the two sets of
chromosomes these two sets of
chromosomes are equal and exactly alike
this leads to formation of two
completely new nuclei which are exact
copy of each other with this mitosis is
complete and each daughter cell has an
identical set of chromosomes after
mitosis the cell undergoes cytokinesis
which is not a phase of mitosis but
rather a separate process necessary for
completing cell division in cytokinesis
the cell also divides its cytoplasm and
cell or can lease and then splits in the
center to form two completely new cells
with this the cell cycle is completed
and when required these two daughter
cells undergo this whole cell cycle
again to make more new cells guys thank
you so much for watching this video if
you found this video and all the other
free educational videos on this channel
helpful you can now support math
simplified on patreon.com for literally
the price of a coffee cup this will
allow me to fund my work and make more
videos like this and will also unlock
some cool patreon only exclusive content
like behind the scenes of these videos
upcoming videos early notifications and
exclusive flash cards and handouts make
sure to subscribe us on YouTube for all
the upcoming videos and also make sure
to follow us on Instagram and Facebook
for flashcards notifications and much
more